in the 1970s portugal's carnation
revolution kicked off a global wave of
democratization
as people across the world demanded
democracy from their governments
throughout the rest of the 20th century
democracy continued to grow
in popularity and legitimacy even the
most powerful autocracies like china and
russia adopted more democratic rhetoric
yet events in the 21st century have
raised concerns about democratic
backsliding
or the gradual shift away from democracy
towards authoritarianism
although the number of total elections
has been increasing
since the mid-20th century the line has
plateaued
and could be slowly declining
a new review in science evaluates
democratic backsliding at the global
level
by examining the conditions that pave
the way for backsliding
and how international support for
democracy has changed
it spotlights democracy scores based on
how well a country conducts fair
elections
protects basic freedoms and holds
elected leaders accountable
1976 marked the beginning of the most
recent wave of democratization
by 1989 countries in latin america
had transitioned from military rule to
democracies
at the turn of the 21st century the same
clustering effect occurred in eastern
europe and sub-saharan africa
but in 2019 democracy scores across the
globe went down
concerns about backsliding are
especially prominent in countries
experiencing nationalist movements
declining trust in government
institutions rising income inequality
and populism
or an ideology that pits pure people
against the self-serving elite
all pose a threat to democratic
governance
a decline in western support for
democracy has intensified these
challenges
support has taken a bigger tumble within
the last four years
than the previous 40. without
international support
citizen movements are more likely to be
suppressed by their local and national
governments
this makes it more challenging to hold
leaders accountable for acts against
democracy
such as stealing elections or limiting
individual rights
hong kong's recent pro-democracy
protests provide a unique example
in 2019 china ruled out a new national
security law that undermined hong kong's
autonomous status
the study says the international support
for hong kong was underwhelming
and it suggests that if the protests had
taken place just three years earlier
they would have met with more powerful
international support
democratic backsliding presents a
daunting reality in the years to come
you